so what's up come in know this walking a
sort of longer yeah it's fun big fan is
nothing when you want to with all this
chance East Coast was South Dakota -
Sergey Canada
we're in ninety homologa cross the
country or three in the u.s. we're
trying to break into the country right
now
so to stop the top line to start with
some of the custom gear activated for
yourself as I see it so I know that I'm
gonna wear that ASAP no I do that I love
it man I love it you gotta create these
customers for after artis is there what
is that a medium I got every size for
his beautiful young larger Solaris good
huh good I'm the medium it alright good
yeah so well and then I got some apps
for you as well love a man I love it man
thank you very much rare rare I'm gonna
sell this on eBay
I love the man and this is some of the
stuff you guys do yes we do all sort of
talking out yeah earlier so we do all
four different designs emerge embroidery
screen print tasks when you start it
three years ago
so for you hauling all your pathology of
these three years you'll watch always
University read Jab Jab right hook so
big fan of your work Thank You Man thank
you man
awesome so I guess we're asking
questions yeah let's do it I just want
to really talk about the clothing
company yeah um you know I I think that
getting into a market is actually
stunningly easy
so I actually genuinely believe you take
the advice about to give you it will
work
I'm surprised how many people overthink
it I think you need to map every single
buying decision maker in America and I
think you need to email them hit them up
on social media and then surprise and
delight them like it's literally that
basic like you actually know the 5,000
stores distribution centers you want to
be in like right and fear and you know
like you want to be an urban alpha
because I don't know you want to be in
this little Soho shop I don't know
that's your business I don't know it but
if I had a wine I sure know which stores
right so great you decide there's 41
boutiques and Soho you want to be a part
of you guys sit on [ __ ] Google find
the person's name send them a t-shirt
and
note in the mail they get millions of
that picture on the garbage of same way
I do
right you email them you follow them on
Twitter and Instagram you talk to them
on Twitter and Instagram you tagged them
in some of your photos on Instagram so
it shows up in your notifications you
one-on-one virtually sell the fifteen
hundred and thirty seven people that
make the decision if this t-shirt goes
on a rack literally a fib row so you
believe that this is for you on a I
think they probably right like the
cooler they are the more ship that gets
them for free all day right I get stuff
sent and you know I get stuff sent all
the time and we're trying very hard not
to like not see it or not respondents
impossible you know I used to get sent
ten thousand whines a second so I don't
think sending it I think it's expensive
and not guaranteed what I would start
with is the virtual stuff first if you
get a nibble uh-huh
you know I mean look so you follow Karen
and she has a rad shop in st. Louis and
she says something about something going
to Canada that's exactly when you guys
jump in and be like your work from
Canada I want to show you around like if
people aren't putting in the work from
the salesmanship what you want and what
I want and what everybody wants in
theory is okay we're going to do this
for Gary B he's going to wear it on
dailyvee we're going to be in it and
they're going to come to us the problem
is that's too insane
everybody wants the leverage of
everything coming to them when they
haven't earned it yet
you've been grinding and getting
somewhere three years in and you still
aren't [ __ ] how cool is that
that's cool and it sucks I love it I
love that I bet like people looking
right at you you know in the last 100
days last four months it's really
starting to pop for me right and it was
like you know how come this is happening
I'm like 20 [ __ ] years of [ __ ]
hustle dick that's why it's happening
you know what I mean you never know when
it's going to be that moment so look
this is smart you got
here this is [ __ ] clean great
exposure there's cool people that watch
great good [ __ ] could happen but you
only think that this thing is going to
be the thing I always thought like okay
disappearance on Jimmy Fallon is going
to be the thing right or or this podcast
with Rogen is going to be the thing or
or this person following me on on social
media is going to be the thing none of
it's the thing it's just another block
another stepping stool and the quicker
you think about like bricks instead of
like a prefab building the quicker you
win you know who the 3,000 decision
makers you know the 400 stores you know
the 1,700 humans one-on-one them
digitally and it takes a lot of time
because by nine hours one day just doing
this because I'm inspired to do it and
four people are going to hit you back no
I think that's [ __ ] I think that I
think that's Little Brother syndrome if
you're the break doesn't have that
problem the end I know it's the truth
like that's just that's excuses that's
that's creating air cover to justify why
it hasn't happened yet you know you guys
sitting around having a beer and they
like [ __ ] you know that's what
Americans do like they don't take us
seriously that's just [ __ ] dwelling
you know to me yes like like when I was
a kid like at school was a big thing I
didn't sit around say well nobody's
gonna take me serious cuz I didn't go to
Harvard I was like I'm just going to do
it and then one day everybody's going to
look back and be like yeah so do you
understand
keep going when you're on your hands
live it yeah when you took this that
back
median cars yes yes how did they react
my dad already had so you gotta remember
people don't get it people confused
right now how big of a deal it was
people thought the internet was a fad it
would be more similar in this in 1996
how old were you in 1996 right so it is
a long [ __ ] time ago held were you in
96 right so I need you guys to wrap your
head around it now it makes sense when I
said we're going to build an e-commerce
site instead of opening another store
that would literally be like you saying
right now I'm going to start a
virtual-reality clothing brand we're not
going to make this you're going to make
pretend you're like people didn't
understand so first of all there was a
lot of like people didn't even know the
[ __ ] I was talking about because it was
so foreign got it
number two I was already in the business
since I was 14 and I already proven to
my dad that I was good you know a lot of
people like to rag on me like oh your
dad had something my dad had something
the people forget that I was making
$2,000 a weekend as a 13 year old child
selling baseball cards so I'd already
proven that I was a like I was already a
whiz kid I'd matter of fact I always
didn't want to go into my dad's business
because I didn't want the [ __ ] trolls
to say oh you have this because I knew I
was right I had it already so you know I
think that a that was already buying why
do you have partners or family members
of up OK
you were just curious yeah two different
peoples in the bottom something to
survive okay I'm just trying to build a
fully straight marketing program
the scale but we just haven't what's
been the biggest breakthrough micro
moment we've had people like Ed Sheeran
where they care a lot on stage can you
like [ __ ] yeah when you were that was
our biggest overall fail night so we
went we got verified on Twitter and we
from him wearing of course it got there
in hose probably punctured a quartile in
the hashtags both left so involved each
player and the next day before the
hundred eighty-five teacher that you
wore that it so how much in sales 105
t-shirts how much I can sure gyrate sake
shirts a consular veto Allah God I got
LASIK big number and you know II just
saw that that was a huge engagement
message acting but I hope that helps you
guys so we were blown away about it did
he do a random where you able hit him up
and get him to one of his best when I
was that she was that comparing that was
our biggest breakthrough and an area
that were really not strong Toronto so
East Coast brand were they Atlantic
Canada and Bing on the west coast people
that Vancouver the proud the prop people
leave to go work in the oil industry or
good jobs and we just kind of have low
impact in the middle but we're really
trying to grow down in New Jersey New
York Philadelphia
Florida in strong disco states got it
better if you believe that this pride
and you go to the US in terms of East
Coast West Course 100% goes back to
offers 100% said complete no-brainer
we have East Coast lifestyle West Coast
lifestyle and yourself both of those
brands online and also in stores across
the country to Canada but really we just
started to deal with zoomies in Canada
so we're trying to prove that we have
strong sales there and look at put it in
us after that so we're really trying to
grow at Langley it's tough for a young
associate of the US market dude I don't
think it's that tough and I know it's
tough
let me explain all you need is one
person that you emailed or one person
you talked to on Twitter Instagram who
owns what the third hottest shop in Soho
in Beverly Hills and you know whenever
alpha whenever that [ __ ] places and
[ __ ] Atlanta I can't remember now the
rich little area where everybody goes
[ __ ] Peachtree your ass [ __ ]
remember like whatever like all you
need food it's only sees one moment but
you have to put yourself in the position
to get those moments like you just
basically have to sit and be in sales
mode on your [ __ ] phone 24/7 365 how
do we get honest we don't know how why
are we here so I the NGO on Instagram I
really don't know if you doing a lot
about a lot of the great way to get in
touch with a lot of yourself
so I reset yourself and then just hit a
collar and then I thought Fowler in
network okay this is probably three
months ago conversation but I just
worked my hat's off so I got I really
want to meet you good do that four
thousand times I'm being dead serious
man you've got to know that missing 11
times and hitting the one time of the 12
times that you stuck 12 hours on is ROI
positive that's or note these [ __ ]
don't get great DM and emailed and
tweeted 17 shop owners that are trendy
and none of them replied that's good
that's good
everybody thinks that's a wasted day
that's a good day because you got your
answer there was no those are just as
good as yeses because you know yeah or
even ask the right way you change it you
guys you too I feel like it three more
how many three yup let's [ __ ] dude you
need to go in the offense it's not going
to come to you and Stephanie a miracle
it's grinding it
you had serendipitously the relationship
with Edie you need to create the other
10,000 it's lay in bed and [ __ ] work
on your you know lucky we are that you
can lay in bed and do this they used to
people like you and I you start to get
on planes and spend the whole day to get
one meeting in Iowa now you just DM them
how the [ __ ] we gonna get to me twenty
years ago you weren't so like come on
this is awesome this is exciting like I
wanna I'm going to start I'm going to
start a brand called Middle America if
you don't do this and show you exactly
how to do it it but you know what I mean
honestly bro it's like don't [ __ ] me
this is very important to me because I
really want you to
and sing like a good kid don't lie what
I'm about to ask you tell me what
happens between 9:00 p.m. and 6:00 in
the morning in your life go tell me the
truth guys until baseball oh good don't
don't build the following biz dev for
distribution got it the business thing
left you're doing too much brand and not
enough selling yes
no more jabs actually more right hooks
in a weird way one more time you're
trying to build hey we have four million
if we have four million Instagram
followers when somebody looks but
they'll be undeniable and they'll put us
in the store I'm saying don't worry
about that because that's going to take
forever anyway Karen Smith the buyer at
[ __ ] prep house sweet where the spot
got it you see where I'm going
no go for the decision-maker that thinks
you're cute that liked your hustle I
have no [ __ ] idea why I told you to
talk to Tyler because what you did to me
I'm having happen 9,000 times a day
some finally I don't remember I don't
know if I liked what your t-shirt I
don't know if I even clicked I don't
know if I decided to randomly just do it
because I like doing this once in a
while and giving back to you guys I
don't know why but it happened but you
need to understand that that can happen
a lot this is not an anomaly and more
importantly this is cool this would be
great for brand and some people gonna
buy some [ __ ] but I didn't just give you
a purchase order and that's what you
need map the 1,500 stores in America
that you need to be in from Nordstrom's
which will be [ __ ] impossible in
corporate to some [ __ ] dude that when
you did your homework oh [ __ ]
crisp combs the radish shop in Minnesota
that does this kind of year
his mom's from Toronto
but you need to think I rather you get
one Beverly Hills shop to put by 15
shirts and try you out through VM versus
you getting 41 more followers on
Instagram
it's the reallocation of your 9:00 p.m.
to 3:00 a.m.
correct you need more of that because
that's that's real and tangible and
needs to happen in parallel to brand
building too many people in the church
t-shirt schwag game are only about
branding and not about sales
everybody's got a brand oh it's
literally every kid watching right now
all she has to do is say okay I'm
calling mine fuzzy peach create a rad
logo and slap it on [ __ ] your
commoditized you know you can you know
everybody can say well my story [ __ ]
your story everybody's got a story you
eat sales distribution and awareness
people work spending too much time of
awareness and not enough on sales and
distribution of the product got it [ __ ]
will come to you a moment will happen
somebody's watching right now that will
just like this is probably going to get
you more distribution anything you've
done people that are going to comment
we're gonna tag you a little handle now
you'll get some DMS from people saying
hey I got with a shop I'll pick some
t-shirts but but you need to force that
Australia they have Shaheed Coast all
right I'm the girl hair is that
we live in Canada and you're trying to
grow over there do the same you know get
out the buyers get out dividers or is it
go on the ground in pipes or fires you
can't go on the ground what are gonna
buy $4,000 [ __ ] Australian flag
ticket and Trek you don't have that
you're going to build an empire from
your bed ready I own your business
Australia spend two days with my team
even if the videos Austin Boston no
today you're not video today you're
[ __ ] on Google Google top [ __ ]
[ __ ] clothing stores in Australia rad
clothing stores in Australia go to
instagram and hashtag Australian
clothing Australian sport like [ __ ]
work on spec get a list okay here 239
shops we want to be a part of on the
East Coast okay now we go to their
website scroll down contact about me
about me Carl tintin tintin started this
because his dad loved these coasts
ex-google Carlton Tintin Carl loves
Australian rules football like like [ __ ]
it work then email and say yo Carl sorry
your team lost last night you know did
it did it then you DM him then you leave
a comment on one of his Instagram foot
so you email him email his website leave
a comment on a post he made on Instagram
and at him on Twitter you guys following
the work got it
so that's what you do what three of
those 39 people say yo send me a shirt
one of those three that you sent sure to
put it in their store one really smoke
show model walks in there where is it
and away you go
do you understand so that's what you do
Australia we're gonna inspect spent
$4,000 to go to Australia you can't do
that right now so something to matter
which option you can't do it the second
one right now really knocked off around
the world off with a lot of rain
using the same circle we have this
trademark the circle logo and they're
changing New York lifestyle Florida
lifestyle for new lifestyle we have it
all protected so we do eventually shut
them down but they're getting one week
to one month of sales online answer
channels that we don't have visible in
Canada and then our followers are saying
any occupation I think that you should
hire you should find a lawyer who you
give 1% of the company to whose boarded
for his job who's that got it
give him one percent equity they had
entrepreneurial tendencies they wish
they started their own business but
they're a lawyer now they have a
mortgage and you give them a little bit
out of action and they [ __ ] cease and
desist of their asses off of course it's
a good idea that's why I came here what
are the 30 times teach your app is he
telling me that you've hardly on this
have you been following me I don't know
what's coming I just react when it comes
musically is a place that I would look
at if I were you because if you get them
at 13 you become a 13 year old brand -
I'm going so I give that some thought
would you guys but they're the
generation said yeah I are the
regeneration wah nope
I love when people break down
generations like Millennials Gen X Gen Z
my love them all they're people you know
13 year-olds don't have as much money
but they're going to be 22 and they're
the ones that can make 20 like you know
so they all have different values more
engage all social business review course
they don't even know the real world I
mean so you know you know better 90
holiday they live in their phone you
mean you live in your phones I live in
my phone
what is this like stuff like you know
any like if there is nothing else so how
do you get how you call how do you give
value to
generation if there I have the body
across or by your grand ok curse I think
it's cool
I'm a big fan of that you know like
little ones to put on their iPhone I
just play you ask them
yeah you know meet up super fun you know
like [ __ ] stuff you know I'd give them
stuff like I'd loose the lowest-cost
thing you can you got to musically start
it's got followers and they're just as
important right so I have musically
personal branch of advice I would I
don't know if musically is going to be
here three or four years now they have
work to do
but the tendencies that they've created
are things that will be mapped in the
future
so like Socialcam taught me more about
snapchat and Instagram than anything
else you don't even know what social cam
is it was hot for 48 seconds
[Music]